relations with China dominated the
heated TV debate between the three
candidates vying for Taiwan's top job as
she bids to secure a second four-year
term president sighing when says Beijing
is the biggest threat to Taiwan's free
and democratic way of life I said um
they went off my rival hyung woo
hesitates when asked which country he
thinks would harmed the well-being of
Taiwan the most let me tell you now that
country is China pang from the Chinese
Nationalist Party or KMT is widely seen
as sighs main challenger he favors
closer ties with Beijing and accuses dye
of exploiting the protests in Hong Kong
to bolster her case Chung Hong Kong's
own battleship Hong Kong's people are
bleeding from fighting against China
President sigh what have you done to
help Hong Kong Hong Kong's people are
bleeding while you are enjoying
electoral games your campaign is based
on the blood of Hong Kong people
pro-democracy demonstrations and Hong
Kong over China's perceived efforts to
curb the territory's freedoms have
ignited concerns in Taiwan some see the
six months of protests in Hong Kong is
giving a timely boost to size
re-election campaign because he a steady
and then a decisive shift in public
opinions in Hong in Taiwan responding to
events in Hong Kong and person in China
benefited from the aggressive approach
of the Chinese government both towards
Taiwan for example over a diplomatic
annoys and over how they handled Hong
Kong woman present Xi Jinping has
emphasized that Taiwan is a renegade
province that needs to be reunified by
force if necessary
China's pressured countries to cut
diplomatic ties with Taiwan the number
of nations retaining relations with the
island has shrunk to 15 and China's
seeking to win favor with voters in
Taiwan by making it easier for Taiwanese
companies to invest in the mainland but
if the opinion polls are correct and
Tsai is re-elected China's efforts are
expected to face a further backlash on
China's eye
neighbor Alexi O'Brien al-jazeera